[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the leadership Society series
people implanted in the information era
and today I'm discussing how Tech
defines us with Professor Kate icorn
chair and professor of culture and media
at the new school thanks for joining us
thanks Brian thanks for the invitation
good so I'm just Jump Right In in your
recent book content you describe a shift
in the way culture products are produced
and consumed and you wrote that in an
age of consent I'm sorry an age of
content content isn't just something
needed to promote ones are increasingly
content is art or at least what has come
to stand in for art when you say content
can you describe what that is
you know I wish I could give you a
really fantastic definition of content
um so a bit of a backstory
I started to like most of of us you know
start to hear this word increasingly
around 2010 2011.
it was maybe 2017 or 2018. I was on a
panel which is actually with the both
people from information studies and
people from media studies and it was a
panel about information how do you
define information how is information
different than data and I realized on
that panel that even Scholars
interrogating the idea of information
were beginning to use this word content
but none of us really could Define it
and I thought okay I'm going to try to
write a book a short book
about this concept and I wish I could
now give you a really fantastic
definition but even after writing the
book I still
I still don't know if I could give you a
great definition of what content is what
I can say is that
it is very context specific
so you can take something
that
also circulates as a film or an artwork
or a piece of literature but in a
particular context it can be redeployed
as as content but we also know
simultaneous to that
over the last
20 25 years there is a lot of stuff
let's call it on the internet that was
just produced as content it was just
purely produced not to convey a message
or share information it was purely con
produced for the sake of circulation
itself so content is both of those
things so there's content that's been
redeployed and becomes content because
of the context and then there's also
just all of that kind of Click bait and
different forms of online
material that was produced just to
create a frame basically for advertising
I see I'm curious about this so let's
think about radios that's been around
for a long time yeah
um and there was always a sense that
like top 40 was being used more to
advertise things than it was for the art
not to say there wasn't art in music is
that content was that content then like
what's the difference between content
and art is it just the use that it's put
to
that's a good that's a good question I
mean I I use the example in my book if
you are an executive at Netflix or
Amazon Prime you might look at a film by
Agnes Farda or Jean-Luc Goddard and
refer to it as content because all it is
for you is its content for your
streaming platform
if you talk to one of my colleagues in
film studies they're not going to refer
to those films as content so it is
content is has seems to have something
to do with how it's being used and why
and that's why it's actually very
difficult to Define because you have
content that's just created to be
content and then you have basically
anything else particularly anything else
that's streamable
that can now be redeployed as content
so it seems like when you say content
you just it's used to fill some channel
it's used to advertise something else is
it just not things that are created for
the intrinsic value of the thing itself
is that is that what we're talking about
in some cases but then you run into this
problem where you have something that
was actually you know produced as art
um as literature that also gets
redeployed by the content industry
and what happens in the process is lots
of the many of the classifications that
we once took for granted we used to
define things in the basis of genre or
Reason to Define things on the basis of
format all of those things get sort of
flattened out
everything sort of gets put into the
same the same pile so to speak and that
creates
some collapse of it's not just a
collapse of categories
there's some important distinguishing
features
um that disappear and then when you
start to talk about things like
misinformation and disinformation the
consequences of that become a bit more
dire
can you say a little bit more about that
so why why is what are the consequences
when you when you talk about
misinformation disinformation
so
in the past we've always had
misinformation and disinformation
there's nothing new about those things
but it usually costs people
so you have to invest in order to
produce that this information and
disinformation and it was fairly
difficult for the average person to
circulate it widely
in an era of content it's pretty easy
and very inexpensive for anyone to
circulate misinformation or
disinformation but another thing has
happened
during the 2016 presidential election
we know that a certain amount of
misinformation and disinformation came
out of control factories in Russia but
there was also that really weird story
of the Macedonian teenagers who
discovered they wanted to make money
online right like lots of folks
um had a domain and they realized that
the articles that would get the most
views and clicks and therefore produce
the most generate the most revenue and
AdSense
happen to be articles about the U.S
presidential election and if they threw
in something that was highly salacious
those articles would even perform better
and so it's an example of how
misinformation and disinformation also
now can be easily monetized so there's
actually an incentive
to produce that kind of content and that
has had Fairly grave consequences for
democracy not just in the United States
but globally this is something that
we're grappling with
let's see I want to come back to the
that in a bit but first I want to go
back to the content creation
um and you've talked about how artists
have to commodify theirselves along with
their art can you can you explain that a
little bit
foreign
yeah again this is a you know
I've been thinking about this question
for quite some time probably since the
early 2000s I started to see this impact
of
the
content industry on poetry visual arts
different different art films but
particularly literature and visual arts
and
one of the things I I wrote about in my
last book is a shift from the field of
cultural production to what I call the
field of of of you know content
production essentially
um in order to in the past if you were a
visual artist you know you'd be making
your art eventually maybe you would have
a Big Show and this would sort of
catapult you into you get great reviews
and this would catapult you into you
know a new stage in your art career
increasingly people are before they have
their first gallery show or Museum show
they're actually discovered on a
platform like Instagram
producing content not necessarily about
their
artwork but about themselves as artists
has become particularly important
um and some might argue specifically for
women artists there's an incredible
Demand on them to produce content about
themselves and so
if I talk to my students who are now
almost all
um born in the 2000s and Beyond you know
so since since 2000 I should say
they would say that in a way this is
incredibly democratizing right so as
opposed to having to go through all the
gatekeeping mechanisms that once
determined you know who who could have a
very successful career as a writer or
artist this is now from their
perspective in your hands right you can
control
um and even circumvent a lot of the
gatekeeping that used to exist in both
the literature and art worlds
um on the flip side of that there is
something
sort of troubling about the extent to
which
artisan and writers now have to produce
content about themselves so as opposed
to focusing on their writing or art
they're really focusing on creating this
kind of online content about themselves
as writers and artists it's as if they
are
you know some of the gatekeeping
mechanisms have collapsed but it's been
replaced
um by creating a situation where artists
and writers have to be their own their
own content directors their own content
producers their own marketers
and so some to some extent what's
happening is I don't know if this is new
you can tell me if you think this is new
but the artist has become part of the
content itself so it's it's this is what
you think you're saying about social
media that they are
um presenting themselves as much as the
art as part of the self-promotion
necessary to become successful is that
is that fair
um particularly for women artists yes
absolutely
um there's an incredible pressure on on
um women in the visual arts younger
women to produce content about
themselves
um so they're sort of part part of the
package and
it's
you know
I I don't want to be again because I I
listen to I work with a lot I work at a
school with a very large art program I
work with a lot of emerging artists and
they're not entirely negative about this
shift and I want to honor their
perspective
but
it does seem that
the artists themselves needs to
put themselves out there and create a
kind of following online and so I you
know what's interesting about this is
when you collapse art and artists you
end up in a in a strange place to some
extent so right now there's been a lot
of talk about say JK Rowling or Roald
Dahl and this is kind of the
um in the space of literature or at
least in in writing
how should we think about the separation
of the art and artists given what you're
saying so if an artist is seen as
problematic should should that from your
perspective I know this is a strange
question as I should but should that
have your perspective or in this world
where content and artists get com
compressed should that change how we
think about the art is that part of the
art then their their their person
I mean
ideally it it isn't right like ideally
we should be able to to
not we've spent you know if we go back
to the sort of theoretical you know
dominant theoretical Trends in the late
in the 80s and 90s and into the early
2000s certainly reading reading the work
of art or a work of literature through
the lens the biographical lens of the
writer artist was something that we
rejected
um but I would agree that it's more
difficult to do that
in this era where the
you know for there's this incredible
sort of pressure on particularly
emerging Artisan writers to have
themselves at the center of the body of
work they're creating
and what's the what's the outcome of
this I mean if you see this this
continuing let's say this um flattening
of Art and artists right this all all
moving towards in some sense what you
would call I think content
what does that do about
what does that do to Art I guess is the
question and this is a this is I feel
like this is getting very abstract but
what I'm asking you is
um
what is the function of art right and so
when we think about people and plan in
the in the information area like art
plays a role in in The Human Experience
so I guess the first question is what do
you think that role is like what's the
point of Art
that's if I could answer that question
Brian
I'd have an you know I would I would
just teach one course a year and you
know
we're teaching at a liberal arts college
with a 2-3 load
um no I mean I I can't answer I can't
answer that question but if you're
asking me what do I think
is the danger of this path that we're
going down
um
and maybe this is really purest that I
don't think that if you are an
Innovative poet or you're you know an
artist working in a a non you know
producing work that doesn't have a lot
of commercial value
that
I I want to preserve a space for people
to engage in that work and you know
because so much of what happens
on
all of these social media platforms is
so driven by the economy
it does create a more narrow space
for artists and writers other you know
cultural workers
to to operate in I would also say it's
the case and this is a bit of a
generalization but the the you know
recent
reports particularly in the visual arts
world would would say that this is
bearing out it's true
that the same you know women often young
women it would be successful influencers
because they're very they're cisgender
they're white they're thin they meet all
of those criteria seem to also have a
lot of success having their work taken
up when they put it online and you know
it leads to shows it leads to you know
great prices and art options and I don't
want to take any of that success away
from people who are using this to their
advantage because again my students
would say this is great because some of
those women you know would not have been
able to be where they are
before the emergence of before they were
able to take all of this and into their
own hands so to speak
um but I do think we need to be aware of
the fact that certain people can
leverage those platforms more
successfully than others and it's about
gender it's about race it's about your
location in the world it's about a whole
number of factors
because at the end of the day this is
going to sound very cynical I do think
that
there are certain kinds of relations of
ruling that are reproduced
on social media platforms so the problem
isn't social media the problem is the
extent to which these platforms have a
tendency
to
reproduce
inequities practices stereotypes that I
think a lot of us would like to
challenge
um
that seems
um that's compelling to me I guess what
I thought in going back to the original
question when I think about art and
artists I I would like to separate them
and I don't know that's probably not
surprising
um and I think of art as something that
elevates and expands right it gives you
a different view into the world through
some other perspective and it helps you
think about the world in in more
interesting maybe ways or deeper ways
um and to me if you don't separate art
and artists it seems like what you
really then end up with are our heroes
and villains or in between something in
between as opposed to perspectives that
you can take on yourself right I I just
want I just I guess I I wonder and and
worry about that in the way you're
describing this kind of collapse of
art and content or artist in in content
um and and I I do want to take a take
back up to where you were on the
technology in terms of the um
kind of supporting the existing systems
and biases and go to it in a slightly
different direction like what are the
consequences you see for it as you point
out the younger Generations dealing with
these new platforms and social media
like what do you what do you see as the
as you think about the your students the
ones who apparently were born in 2000 or
later
uh what do you see as as the
consequences for this generation given
the the move towards or the the shift
towards social media
I mean there have been there been
consequences for for all of us
um so I don't necessarily think it's
just age age related I mean I guess I'll
throw the the question back at you Brian
are you implying that the consequences
are negative
question
um I think that's basically what you're
asking me is like what and I'm I'm very
cautious as a media studies scholar
um to you know not assume that the
Technologies can't be used against the
grain of their original intention well
are you assuming the original intention
was negative
um I assume that it's a tool and I
assume the tools
um will be used in ways that are
um most useful or most gratifying to
people who are given who are who have
access to them
um I think that
if you're asking me given the point
where you're making about artists if
there was a fear The Gatekeepers or
since The Gatekeepers were preventing
people from being successful then and
the tools LED them circumvent that then
that's what people will use the tools
for that's kind of what I assume so I
don't necessarily assume that the tools
themselves are good or bad but
I do worry and that we've had
conversations in this series already
that about this that I don't know that
people thought carefully about how the
tools could be misused and that seems
problematic to me
um it's it's it seems to me
that you could you some of things some
of the things that have happened that I
think we could agree on we'll talk about
this in a bit are not the best could
have been predicted I don't know how far
in advance but to some extent we're
foreseeable and people didn't seem to be
that concerned even when they were hints
that for example it might be affecting
mental health for example the negativity
was particularly powerful and easy to
spread when people have started to have
a sense that that was true I don't think
we backtracked so in that sense I think
it's problematic but that's not the
tools
themselves that's how they were used and
how they were monetized and these sorts
of things
well I often ask myself you know
2021 when The Whistleblower
um thing happened at Facebook when it
was still called Facebook right
um it wasn't really a surprise to anyone
that they had done studies showing that
their platforms particularly Instagram
had had this negative impact on the
mental health of girls and women in
particular
um you know if you think about going
through
childhood or adolescence and getting a
metric every time you have a social
interaction it sounds pretty horrifying
right so it's probably going to be bad
for your mental health so I don't think
anyone was surprised but what I keep
asking myself Ryan is you know you said
I think people
I think we saw this coming
but I'm not you know I'm not sure like
when when did we see it coming I think
that by maybe 2015 or 2016 that there
was a
kind of heightened cynicism or at least
awareness about privacy questions so
around the time that I was writing the
end of forgetting I think definitely
people were beginning to
shift but if we go back to
2005 or 2006 2007.
I don't know do people anticipate
what this world that we're living in now
in 2005 no I don't know I mean first of
all like I can't even remember what 2005
was so let me just because
um there was a pandemic something some
stuff happened between then and now that
it makes it a little bit
um but you know I think if you were to
ask
a science fiction writer or someone that
predict out in the future I think it
wouldn't it wouldn't take too hard to
generate a dystopian future based on the
technologies that were being produced
once you had things like likes and I
mean if anyone let me let me say it
differently anyone who's been in middle
school should have been like um this
might not go well
so I don't know when we figured figured
it out but I I don't I mean I don't know
what other people's Middle School
experience was but if you told me we're
gonna put everything that you do
on this public forum and then we're
going to let people vote on how they
feel about it more or less and then
we're going to have you look at that all
the time that would not sound good to me
it no exactly right I think everyone I
think everyone would have agreed that
that was going to be a really you know
terrible
terrible idea
um but for whatever reason we just all
kind of sat back and watched it happen
right and like that's that is what is so
interesting to me I think if we also go
back to that time
um I've been working on this new book
about it's a it's on a kind of funny
topic it's actually about the history of
high school yearbooks just speaking of
horrible you know experiences and
Adolescence and one of the things I
discovered is um
that a lot of the information now used
for people search companies
um but also all of those images on
ancestry.com sites like that
there are tens of thousands of images
that come from high school yearbooks
and so during that early part of the
internet we were actually taking you
know 2005 2006 2007 that's when people
begin to collect all these materials and
start to digitize them we couldn't quite
have anticipated
how they were going to end up being used
and I think that that that is that is
why a lot of these problems happened is
that we might have seen something
terrible coming but we didn't know
how we were all contributing to it
because I think that that that's what's
is troubling is that we're all part of
the problem
right we were all sharing our materials
we were scanning things we were tagging
things online we were liking things and
so we're all part of the larger problem
that we're now trying to Grapple with
and not everybody wants to take
responsibility that's true I agree with
that completely I think we all
participated you know to differing level
so I I don't think anyone is completely
innocent I think there's something about
human nature that makes these things
compelling which is why you have I don't
know whatever it is five billion people
on on Facebook or something like that I
I wonder how do you think this is has
changed us
or is changing us do you think that we
were different not just as a society
obviously there's been a lot of changes
in how Society functions because of
social media but do you think people are
different do we have different
expectations of each other do we have
different expectations of ourselves do
we think about our futures differently
like are we different
because of these changes
in in many different
ways I mean I think that our
relationship to the past has changed
I think we um
you know one of the things that
motivated me to write the end of
forgetting was just thinking about
you know I realized around 2015 2016 how
profoundly different the experience that
the students arriving in my first year
classes was compared to the experience I
had back in the late 1980s going off to
college you know I just left
maybe I stayed in touch with a couple of
people it was incredibly selective it
was very much in my control and I just
started my life again
um students now arrive in college with
this whole network of people
in some cases people they've been
connected to since they were in
kindergarten or first grade
and so they're traveling through life
with this sort of
in a way it's it's beautiful because
they're Tethered to the Past in a way
that you couldn't be before but you also
give something up and that has clearly
had some kind of profound
psychological social cultural impact on
us and I think we're still working out
the extent to which that's the case
I mean it's I'm happy brought up in
forgetting this is I'm really interested
in in how you how you think about that
do you think of given a choice people
would say like yeah if I could remember
everything about my life I would or
would they say like no I I'm if as
opposed to not being able to selectively
forget but just things are going to be
forgotten but Brian have you seen any of
those films but what happens when you
can't forget anything
indeed I have but people seem to be
opting for that right is that not what
we're is that not in part what you're
saying is happening
yeah and I think I just think I mean we
we know that we actually forget more
negative than positive things that
happen to us you know we know that
um
you know you have to forget certain
things in order to learn new things
for me forgetting
is is on the one hand forgetting is
incredibly dangerous so particularly
political forgetting right so forgetting
about atrocities forgetting about
um you know all the inequities have
structured our past is a problem and I'm
you know the still I wrote I spent
before I wrote that book I spent many
years writing about about archives and
and working in memory studies so I still
have that position but I also think if
you remember
too much you give up the freedom to
reimagine yourself and to imagine a a
different world so for me there is um
um
it's a psychological
um question but I'm not a psychologist
so I think about this more in terms of
the political consequences
yeah you know I am a psychologist so I
do think about those consequences
[Laughter]
um the thing I wonder or worry about it
changing is our ability to evolve right
so as for most of us I assume that
there's some version of who we were in
the past that we are happy we are now
that we we see that as growth and change
in ways that we
um hold dear and it's a big part of who
we are at this moment that we were
something in the now or something else
and something better and I wonder if not
being able to forget makes it harder
to evolve
I wonder if you have a sense of that
well there's two things I mean there's
there's the kind of
forgetting your past so you can not just
feel you know ashamed and humiliated and
immobilized right by you know mistakes
you've made or things you've said that
you regret Etc
but there's also
um
being the importance of being forgotten
by others
so much of our ability to keep changing
and evolving has to do with others not
remembering everything we ever said
everything we ever did and holding us to
that and I felt a lot about how
our current political situation and it's
sort of
increasingly calcified
sort of positioning of people's politics
is related to the inability to forget
and be forgotten
and so if you think about
you know your digital footprint kind of
defining Who You Are
it is much more difficult for people to
change their political position now than
it was in the past
because it might mean trying to
completely reinvent yourself from
scratch on every social media platform
that you've ever logged on to
and that you know is is itself an
incredible
an incredible challenge we also know of
all those incidents where people are
held
you know asked to account for something
they said online 15.
16 17 years ago sometimes when they were
in middle school or early high school
and maybe that's good right again I
think that my own kids and a lot of my
the students I teach would say yeah if
you say something problematic online
you have to live with that for the rest
of your life and that's good
but it does make it challenging for
people
to reimagine or reposition themselves
um
psychologist here Kate I'm just going to
tell you
pardon he sounds a lot like a
psychologist here
that that book that that book was uh was
sort of taken up in in Psychology and
and I'm I'm always saying interviews but
I I'm not a psychologist so I can't I
can't I tell Dad I don't want to I don't
want to get out of my Lane Brian I hear
you I hear you well I get out of my Lane
all the time
so I I do want to
um pick up on something you said
um people say things online let's say
when they're teenagers and then they're
in their 20s right now and and they
still are
having lived that down or can't live
that down I wonder how this absence of
forgetting affects forgiveness and you
also pointed to like maybe that's good
maybe that's bad like what what is it
what are these Technologies doing to the
ability for us
to allow people to change
I think they're making it more difficult
um it's
you know
not only are people more likely to end
up living in these very kind of small
narrowly defined filter Bubbles and not
to bump into other ideas that they don't
already sort of support
that simultaneous to that
we have
you know everyone's
detritus is sort of out there right and
it can be very difficult for for people
to
reinvent themselves adopt a new position
and then integrate themselves into a
different community and so on the one
hand again some people would say well
you know it's great that there's this
heightened accountability but if that
heightened accountability closes off the
opportunity for Change and
transformation particularly
the kind of
change in perspective you might undergo
when you leave home and go to college
and encounter new people in a new
context
that that worries me you know
um so I do think it's it's it's impacted
people's ability to forgive
as well
yeah I mean it certainly seems that way
and it also and this is something else
you've been pointing to it also seems to
limit Serendipity a little bit right so
you it's easy to find
people like you to be with the people
who you've known in the past to maintain
to generate a community that feels
comfortable and safe and to make that
maintain that Community long term but
also that also seems to be on the other
side like a loss in Serendipity and
possibility and and just Discovery and I
wonder if that's also a part of the not
forgetting is are those things related
in your mind I I think they are and I'm
gonna pause it for one second in order
to plug in my computer can you believe
that I didn't plug in my computer before
the interview wrong it happens it
happens I I was thinking you know then
then we could just forget this whole
conversation
I I will run to another meeting and
maybe forget everything that we've
discussed yeah
but you know what it will be on YouTube
okay let's pick it up with with the
Serendipity now that I'm I'm at one
percent and on my way back up again
um
absolutely
so I do think that
you know
the
the surprise the
um
the unexpected
um you know the the
delightful coincidence all of those
things seem to be constrained
when
we find ourselves
in this this space where everything is
always is always being
kind of
tracked and reproduced and and fed back
to us would you agree with that
yeah I think so I mean I I this is
something I thought uh quite a bit about
because I think I mentioned when we
started that I have I have a book about
the construction of self and one of the
chapters is a bit about this that
um
the technology is making it hard for us
to have that Serendipity that the the
surprise in terms of the way the self
expands and I don't know I personally
think it the Delight in learning
something about yourself that you didn't
know
um I think it's harder to do that
um with the way current Technologies
function and so that seems to me to be a
loss at the same time as you pointed out
no Technologies are inherently good or
bad I think it's also really powerful
that people can generate communities
that
um feel safe for them and maintain those
communities and and when in the past
that might have been really difficult to
do so I do think there are there
benefits on the other side yeah well
that's like another question is you know
and I was going to sort of post this
earlier on
is
on the one hand
there are definitely political movements
that have been able to
coalesce and and gain a kind of
visibility that they wouldn't have uh
been able to do in the past or been able
to to accelerate at a pace that would
have not been possible back in let's say
the 90s
um
but
have we seen the emergence of
communities
that have had a real
political impact and I so I'm thinking
like on the one hand I can say you know
as a queer person I definitely would say
that you know the internet has been
um
had an incredible impact on the lives of
the lgbtq youth and it's not a
coincidence that early on even on like
sites like geocities there were trans
teenagers creating communities on those
very early you know user sort of sort of
user friendly
um virtual sites like geocities
on the other hand the
you know the same
the same platforms over time have been
used to perpetuate a lot of hate
and I I'm currently teaching a course on
digital feminism and we're spending
quite a bit of time reading about black
digital feminism so on the one hand it's
been this incredible space for black
women to connect
and you know gain a kind of visibility
and that that didn't exist before and
then on the other hand we're also living
in a Time Rife with sexism and racism
and a lot of rights have been rolled
back so how do we grapple with that
yeah I mean
and I've had this I've had this debate
with a few people
um
like on the one hand obviously
um it's just a tool and as an organizing
tool it can be really powerful the thing
that I point to that is gets me not in
trouble but starts the turns the debate
into a a friendly argument is that I say
something like I don't know that it
deepens connections within the community
meaning it may be you can generate a big
community in part because it's easy and
there's a cost to that ease which is
that it's not as deep and as committed
and as organized as it would be if you
went through the some more
um traditional channels of meeting
people and organizing
um and you know I think that's debatable
but to your point of have we seen
communities that have had deep political
impact I think deep political impact
requires a kind of on the ground
organizing that may not be as easy to do
online as the simple Act of finding
supportive people
yeah I mean I think about this one you
know particularly if you're on a site
like you know it's not even really a
social media site but something like
LinkedIn
and so there'll be lots of posts
um you know prominent minority leaders
in business and that's great okay so
there's this on the surface it looks
like Corporate America is changing
but on the ground we know
who's being paid less whose working
conditions are are problematic
um who has fewer opportunities for for
promotions right and so I I sometimes
feel
that that visibility
creates an illusion of progress
um it particularly in the in the
corporate sector
I want to say one thing that's really
cynical and I'm going to move on that
maybe it may be that that is some of
what some actors want right it provides
an opportunity to present a version of
the organization or the self that that
provides a benefit without having to
actually do
the hard work
um and even even in people's personal
lives this is this is not cynical this
actually happened I was at a dinner I
don't know some years ago five years ago
or something
and there was a person that was about to
go on a date with someone they met on
online some online online dating app and
I don't know what happened but I said oh
do you meet people and you know where I
was in New York you meet people at bars
wherever she's like why would I ever do
that like I can't vet those people like
in essence it's like horribly
inefficient to just meet people on the
street or and you know and through
Serendipity because now I have to go
through the time and effort of figuring
out things about this person and
learning about this person where I can
just read their resume and decide
whether I want to at least have is a
pre-screen whether I want to spend any
time with them or not so I think
both for different reasons but corporate
entities and individuals
um understand
to some extent the value of what's being
offered
um and and this is again my cynical view
like I'm taking advantage of that in our
aren't so concerned about
what others would perceive as the cost
like a corporation maybe they don't want
to do the hard work of figuring out I
deal with
um inequity because it's a lot it's hard
you know but you also want to
demonstrate to people that you care
about it
right this is that's why you hire this
comes back to our original discussion
about content so you hire content
strategist to make sure that you know on
LinkedIn and other sites you look like
the company that is doing all of these
things whether or not you're actually
doing them doesn't really matter
but I think individuals are doing some
version of that too right like
individuals are saying like how can I
take make use of this without all how
can I cut back on some of the hard work
that I normally have to do and get what
I want out of life without going
actually having to talk to real people
right so I you know it's I think it's
all around you see
maybe people changing
um and incorporating these tools into
how they live
to optimizing their their their
sociality
but of course they're not they're not
writing the algorithm right so then you
know this person you're talking to
they're relying on you know the grinder
or tinders algorithm to vet who they're
they're going to go on a date with right
it would be different if we were coming
up with
you know all the criteria
but they're not
um so we're just getting this really
particular version or lens fed back to
us
great so now I'm going to move away from
my cynicism for a moment and okay
I was expecting you to be a lot more
optimistic so
give me a little bit more time with me
okay get to spend more time with me
[Laughter]
um so
this obviously costs to the kind of the
direction we've gone in particular with
social media and as you've mentioned a
number of times particularly like young
women and girls have have we've seen
High rates of depression and negative
mental health outcomes as a function of
Engagement with social media
um Josh Howley recently suggested we ban
kids from social media band social media
from kids depending however you want to
say it what do you what do you think
about that stance
well you know I always think I I tried
to ban television in
might have to say my kids watch a lot of
TV when they were growing up they just
watched it on their phone instead so you
know it
both on a personal level and if we look
at the sort of long history of
attempting to ban different types of
media particularly for children it never
works people have tried to ban radio
comic books films you know
um games people are still trying to ban
games
um because apparently they lead everyone
to become violent
um
yeah so that I don't agree with I also
think
you know the fact that young people
children and adolescents for the first
time in history are able to document
their own lives
and broadcast those images and texts
widely is really incredible that's
incredible it's it's really exciting
that they no longer have to rely on
adults to do that for them
um
that said I I would be more interested
in focusing not on the problem with
social media platforms but how they have
come to be used in their relationship to
capitalism and if I can say it
neoliberalism right so I see social
media platforms
extending or amplifying
practices that have already been in
place for a very long time and that is
what I think we need to address not the
platforms themselves
um and maybe this comes back to
something I said earlier on the one hand
you know we're all of us you and I
everyone who's listening to this we're
all responsible for kind of for creating
this mess
that is social media in 2023
and Beyond
but because we're responsible for
creating it we have some small hope of
maybe changing it for the better
good that leads me to my last two
questions or let's call it a combo
question okay
as you think about how
the air of content creation the social
media how that's changed how we live
um it's changed in this conversation
it's it's changed how we relate to our
pasts
um it changes how we engage with each
other and in some sense the thing has
changed us in some significant way like
the society but also us as individuals
how we engage with the world as you
think about that and you think about the
future what are your fears and what are
your hopes
I mean my
my fear is that
people think complacency is the only way
forward
that that we forget
that we can make choices we we can't
undo what we've created I think that um
you know to come back to our early
conversation about you know when like
when did we see that this was going to
go down a bad path and and decide not to
to prevent it from happening
um that's a hard question to answer but
I do think that we need to even though
we can't undo everything
I think it's important for everyone to
remember that they can potentially shift
the situation we currently have and my
hope is that
um
that we Embrace that challenge
you know I don't think we're going to
sometimes you know people talk about is
it possible to have a search engine
that's not connected to advertising is
it possible you know and I I don't I'm
not that optimistic but I do think that
there are
that we can make inroads into building a
more equitable
um safer less exploitative online space
well I I certainly hope we can share
that hope with you uh thank you so much
for taking the time I really appreciate
it
thanks Brian I really enjoyed the
conversation great so this is our last
conversation in the people and planet in
the information era series uh if you
want to stay in touch with the program
uh and hear my podcast you can visit
know what you see.com
um and thanks for joining us see you all
next time
[Music]
thank you